the bts army fans are here in full force
at allegiant stadium as you can see
hundreds of people are already here fans
tell me they've been waiting in line
since 2 am this morning to snag some
exclusive merchandise and beat the rush
and the heat tonight is the first day of
the group's four-day concert bts fans
from all over the world flocking to
allegiant stadium some as far as canada
and mexico these fans are quite loyal
waiting in line for hours and dropping
hundreds of dollars they say it's worth
it as bts's music has been a source of
inspiration to help them through tough
times my mom had surgery so she was
recovering i was in hospital i started
searching for videos and stuff online
and when she was recovering she watched
them with me and cancer remission she's
in remission now so that's when i found
them so when people say
you find bts when you need them you find
bts when you need them i think their
stamp on the world is to tell people
that don't limit yourself no matter what
you think no matter what you feel like
your limit is it's not the sky is the
limit as long as you make it that the
four concerts are spread out over two
weekends tonight and tomorrow as well as
next weekend mary jane balleza live
local now